don't mean to be
having young young people take two hours
of their time or to just sit and enjoy a
movie um
no this is a learning experience
that also doesn't mean that you take
notebook and you write down everything
in the notes as you're watching the film
because you can't see the film
so what you're doing is training the eye
and the heart
of the student
to look at a film in a different way by
asking questions and pointing to
different different ideas different
concepts
suggestions we don't mean to be
having young young people take two hours
of their time or to just sit and enjoy a
movie um
uh no this is a learning experience uh
that also doesn't mean that you take a
notebook and you write down everything
in the notes as you're watching the film
because you can't see the film
so what you're doing is training the eye
and the heart
of the student
to look at a film in a different way by
asking questions and pointing to
different different ideas different
concepts
suggest